[Musik]
hallo und herzlich willkommen zur
letzten folge militär des jahres schön
dass sie wieder mit dabei sind
wir zeichnen ja in vier kategorien die
angehörigen des österreichischen
bundesheeres für besondere leistungen
aus sowie die sonderkategorie für die
miliz in dieser folge dreht sich nun
alles um den soldat des jahres hier gibt
es für sie einen kleinen überblick der
nominierten in alphabetischer
reihenfolge
nominiert als soldat des jahres sind
kevin brunner der als eine junge mutter
von einem geisteskranken täter auf
offener straße niedergestochen wird
setzt der den täter mit einer gezielt
eingesetzten nahkampf technik außer
gefecht und führt bei der verletzten
frau erste hilfe maßnahmen durch
oberstleutnant jörg leute als
umsichtiger kommandant gelingt die mann
kader anteil von 100% außerdem werden
sieger in wichtigen internationalen
panzer wettkämpfen erreicht
oberstabsarzt meister gerd breker nick
absolviert einen neunmonatigen
auslandseinsatz in afghanistan
der unteroffizier muss durch den ausfall
des kommandanten die offiziers funktion
fünf monate lang übernehmen und wird
dafür ausgezeichnet
der soldat des jahres wird das war es
unsere verteidigungsministerin klaudia
tanner
sehr geehrte damen und herren es ist mir
eine ganz besonders große freude heute
den sieger für den award militär des
jahres bekannt geben zu dürfen
ich bin überzeugt davon dass sehr viele
unsere bediensteten diesen preis
verdienen würden doch es kann immer nur
einen sieger geben
um dieser sieger ist im heurigen jahr
oberstadt meister gerd breker nic
herzliche gratulation oberstabsarzt
meisterbrief war 2010 lehrgangsbester
bei der stabsunteroffiziers ausbildung
er ist heeres bergführer gehilfe erich
schiller heeres meister um vize heeres
meistermannschaft orientierungslauf und
gewinner der edelweiss herausragende
leistungen doch nominiert wurde
oberstabsarzt meister panik weil er in
seinem neunmonatigen auslandseinsatz in
afghanistan außergewöhnliches geleistet
hat durch den ausfall des kommandanten
und national point of contact austria
musste er diese offiziers funktion für
fünf monate übernehmen
januar ab diesem zeitpunkt musste der
unteroffizier zusätzlich zu seinem
eigenen aufgabenfeld der planung und
durchführung der tätigkeiten als advisor
der afghanischen streitkräfte
die österreichischen teile in masar i
scharif führen und an den
internationalen besprechungen teilnehmen
damit verbunden war auch die wahrnehmung
der aufgaben des national point of
contact und die notwendigkeit des
permanenten kontaktes zum simyo national
repräsentativ in kabul oberstabsarzt
meister gerd meister diese höherwertige
aufgabe so umsichtig und bravourös dass
am ende seines einsatzes von
kommandierenden brigadegeneral
ausgezeichnet wurde der oberstabsarzt
meister ich gratuliere ihnen ich
gratuliere ihnen sehr herzlich
dieser hervorragenden leistung alles
gute
der oberstabsarzt meister ich freue mich
ganz besonders die auszeichnung zum
soldaten des jahres 2020 überreichen zu
dürfen
soldat des jahres 2020 gerd bregenz
geboren am 10 märz 1978 in villach im
jahr 2000 ausmusterung zum wachtmeister
2010 absolvierte des stabsunteroffiziers
ausbildung als lehrgangsbester seine
heimat sind die berge fragen wie diese
so schönes genieße die umgebung der
cannabis in medien über mich nachdenken
über meine ziele nachdenken
harris bergführer rs skilehrer sieger
der edelweiss raid das alles und mehr
verbindet gerd breker mit seiner heimat
oder so vorgehen wieder beim
hochgebirgsregionen 26 spital eingerückt
bin und mich von anfang an der berg und
der sport einfach fasziniert und deshalb
im jahresvergleich soll dort bei megabad
[Musik]
einer seiner absoluten lieblingsplätze
in kärnten ist der fall katze für kinder
haben weil die landschaft einfach super
ist passé so schön ist und da hinten
gegelt und da wo wir einen klettersteig
und einfach das werk gefühl in mir
aufnehmen deshalb bin ich drauf herum
probieren
[Musik]
[Applaus]
jeden tag her hin und her und der
schlimmen vorfall in den berg
wunderschöne und beeindruckende bilder
aus kärnten wir gratulieren herzlich dem
soldaten des jahres oberstabsarzt
meister gerd präger league das war es
von uns wir haben nun alle fünf
kategorien durch und sagen noch mal
herzlichen glückwunsch an alle
nominierten und ausgezeichneten und
wünschen ihnen alles gute
bleiben sie gesehen
[Musik]